[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sans public on est
ensemble pour 90 minutes de débat de
chronique et le reportage 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité grâce
à nos invités experts et grâce aux
journalistes de la rédaction de Public
Sénat Elisabeth borne va-t-elle pouvoir
continuer d'utiliser le 493 jusqu'à la
fin du mois de juin le Conseil
constitutionnel n'a pas vraiment répondu
à la question ce jeudi après-midi une
chose est sûre l'exécutif est toujours
dans une impasse politique comment
réformer le pays avec une opposition qui
a prouvé sa capacité à bloquer l'examen
de texte à l'Assemblée les discussions
entre la première ministre et les
leaders de la droite et du centre
peuvent-elles sortir cette loi
immigration de lornière réponse dans une
minute et puis dans notre second débat
on fera le bilan des progrès fulgurant
de l'intelligence artificielle de plus
en plus savante quasi gratuite elle
envahit déjà nos bureaux nos écrans nos
maisons certains commencent à se poser
des questions comme le professeur Benj
c'est l'un des père fondateurs de la et
si leurs objectifs ne correspondent pas
à ce que nous on veut justement les
questions éthique qu'est- qu'est-ce qui
est bon qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui est adéquat qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qu'on désire qu'est-ce qu'on a
comme valeur euh ces systèmes là pourrai
prendre des décisions qui nous nuisent
et même mettent en danger l'espèce
humaine des métiers vont disparaître
d'autres sont en train de muter certains
vont se créer évidemment une chose est
sûre notre espèce humaine doit apprendre
à vivre à travailler avec l'intelligence
artificielle comment la maîtriser ne
ratez pas notre débat sur ce thème ce
sera dans trois quart d'heure mais
d'abord la première ministre en première
ligne elle a repris la main pour tenter
de sauver le texte immigration Flora
sauvage tractation de la dernière chance
pour l'exécutif les discussions se
poursuivent à Matignon au 2è jour des
négociations pour un accord sur le
projet de loi immigration en vue de la
commission mixte paritaire prévue lundi
le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
daranin estime désormais qu'il faut se
rapprocher du texte du Sénat largement
durci par rapport au projet du
gouvernement on est prêt évidemment à
tendre la main au LR au centrist et de
trouver un compromis le plus rapidement
possible puisqu'on doit lundi avoir
cette commission mixte paritaire après
la motion de rejet adopté par les
députés Elisabeth borne a repris le
dossier en main reçu hier par la chef du
gouvernement le président
on peut trouver un accord on a regardé
les points difficiles la me par exemple
am voilà l'aide
médicale ça peut faire l'objet d'un
texte séparé outre l'aide médicale
d'État qui pourrait faire l'objet d'une
loi spécifique en février la majorité
sénatoriale a fixé une ligne rouge pas
question de toucher à l'article 4 bis
qui prévoit de placer sous la
responsabilité des préfets la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papiers dans les métiers intention notre
position sera intangible on ne peut pas
repasser à un droit opposable par les
les étrangers en situation régulière
autrement ça veut dire que on fait
passer la politique migratoire des main
de l'État aux mains des passeurs et ça
c'est non face au LR les députés de la
majorité sont résignés à infléchir le
texte vers la droite le Sénat a demandé
que ce soit que le préfet qui décide
nous ce que nous voulons c'est qu'il
soit écrit les les les obligation dans
la loi pour que ce soit les mêmes
partout en France parce qu'est-ce qui se
passe à l'heure actuelle
sur ce dossier l'exécutif marche sur un
fil en cas d'échec il abandonnerait son
projet de loi à l'inverse en cas
d'accord le compromis de la commission
mixte paritaire sera soumis au vote des
députés et des sénateurs dès mardi
prochain une réunion de la dernière
chance entre les républicains et
Élisabeth borne est prévu dimanche soir
à
matigth prière Lig pourer tir de l'ma
c'est le thème de notre débat avec
Rachel gara Valcarcel bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste politique au
quotidien 20 Minutes Jean garig bonsoir
et bienvenue historien président du
Comité d'histoire parlementaire et vous
publiez jours heureux quand les Français
rêvaient ensemble aux éditions Paillot
j'accueille également Mathilde Etman
patin bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
professeur de droit public à
l'Université du Man et Tam tranui
bonsoir Tam dans le rôle d'éditorialiste
politique ce soir bienvenue à vous euh
la première ministre on vient de
l'entendre qui prévoit donc de retrouver
les leaders de la droite dimanche soir à
à Matignon euh Rachel gar ça veut dire
quoi il y a moi j'y vois un double
objectif il y a sauver le le le texte
immigration et puis aussi réussir là où
Gérald darmana a échoué il y aurait un
petit présir personnel quand même pour
pour Elisabeth borne ouais complètement
là on est déjà dans un quelque chose de
comment dire d'anormal pour une CMP
d'habitude c'est surtout les rapporteurs
du Sénat et de l'assemblée qui qui
négocient là c'est au plus haut niveau
du gouvernement c'est vrai que déjà ça
c'est très marquant d'un point de vue
communication sachant que ça fait des
mois que précisément sur ce dossier-là
ellisabeth borne laisse faire le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui prétendait
jusque- là pouvoir trouver une majorité
on sait ce qu'il en est advenu lundi
Jean garig il y a il y a pour bien
comprendre l'équation de de de cette
semaine ça a démarré lundi il faut quand
même on vient de l'évoquer rapidement
mais parler de la relation borne
d'armanin vous avez beaucoup étudié la
relation président Premier ministre mais
là il y a il y a quand même quelque
chose de l'ordre de l'inimitié il faut
le dire oui d'ailleurs c'est c'est c'est
pas nouveau qu'il a comme ça des
rivalités entre Premier ministre et puis
un ministre qui éventuellement
lorgnerait sa place c'est arrivé entre
manuel Vals et Jean-Marc Kud à une
époque enfin on pourrait citer beaucoup
d'exemples de et là en l'occurrence
manifestement Géral haranin avait fait
de son de sa marche irrésistible vers le
pouvoir son son objectif et et
s'appuyait sur cette sur cette loi sur
ce projet pour s'installer comme un
candidat potentiel à la succession et on
voit bien que du côté d'Élisabeth borne
qui par ailleurs ne l'oublions pas
représente un autre côté de de de la
macronist c'estàd qui vient GAE et donc
ne partagez pas forcément toutes les
tous les projet de de de geréral
Darmanin il y avait forcément un
décalage et on peut imaginer d'ailleurs
je pas le seul à le dire enfin tout le
monde le sait qui une certaine
satisfaction finalement à pour pour
ellisabeth borne à reprendre la main sur
ce sur ce projet ce qui ne veut pas dire
que elle se félicite de ce qui s'est
passé et que personne n'avait
véritablement anticipé du côté de la de
la macronie mais en tout cas l'idée que
ça soit elle qui puisse trouver une
solution dans cette phase pro TR
commission mix paritaire c'est quelque
chose qui pour elle sera quand même par
rapport à lui une victoire mais alors ce
qui est intéressant aussi c'est que des
facto ce serait aussi une victoire pour
la gauche donc de de la macronie or
cette gauche là elle va être confrontée
au durcissement du texte et là il y a un
problème ouais mathildeman patin il y a
depuis lundi moi ce qui me frappe aussi
c'est que à la fois dans les les
oppositions à l'assemblée qui avaient
décidé qui se sont coalisés pour cette
motion de rejet et dans la la ligne de
défense d'Élisabeth borne il y a un
procès en irresponsabilité vous piétinez
le la démocratie parlementaire et cetera
on se renvoie ses arguments des deux
côtés sauf puisque quand par exemple LFI
accuseent rappelle qu'éisabeth borne a
utilisé le
493 à X reprise sauf que en fait tous
ces outils sont dans la Constitution
personne ne piétine le le le travail
parlementaire et puis ça c'est ça s déjà
vu enfin la la situation en fait d'une
du Sénat qui adopte un texte et de la
l'assemblée qui rejette et ça entraîne
une commission mix paritaire on l'a vu
avec la loi OGM en 2008 alors ça
commence à dater un petit peu mais le
Conseil avait d'ailleurs été saisi le
Conseil constitutionnel de la question
est-ce qu'on peut réunir une CMP si vite
et le Conseil a dit mais il y a
absolument aucun problème il y a eu un
désaccord entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale le Sénat a voté un texte
l'assemblée a refusé de voter ce texte
l'assemblée a décidé d'adopter une
motion de rejet enfin ça s'appelait pas
comme ça à l'époque mais on va passer
les détails et donc il est possible
parce qu'il eu un désaccord après une
lecture dans chaque assemblée je
rappelle qu'il y a une procédure
accélérée donc on pouvait aller plus
vite de réunir une commission mixte
paritaire est-ce qu'on peut même dire
que c'est à ça que sert la commission
mixte paritaire pas seulement mais
souvent B la commission mixte paritaire
est faite justement pour mettre d'accord
alors la situation un peu spécifique
vous avez commencé à l'évoquer mettre
d'accord l'Assemblée et le Sénat qui ne
parviennent pas à un accord en
l'occurrence ici on n'est pas
complètement sur un désaccord Sénat
assemblée mais plutôtle c'est un peu
plus complexe mais en tout cas à mettre
d'accord des des des n'ar pas à'entendre
pouroutir un texte commun Tam on va
rentrer dans le détail de cette séquence
où où effectivement la la la première
ministre reprend la main oui elle avait
annulé hier et bien ce qu'elle devait
faire son déplacement à Genève la Suisse
le calme la paix les Alpes la neutralité
perpétuelle pour revenir donc sur le
champ de bataille du projet de loi
immigration elle a les mains dans le
camboui le projet de loi occupe et bien
tout son agenda de premierère ministre
depuis hier c'est le grand défilé dans
les salons de Matignon se succède
représentant LR udi et majorité
aujourd'hui c'était la même chose ce
soir elle reçoit 16 ministres pour faire
un point sur le projet de loi
immigration avant de se rendre devant
l'intergroupe de la majorité à
l'Assemblée puis c'est le même programme
pour ce weekend un volontarisme qui
tranche on l'a dit avec son attitude
passée puisqu'elle avait laissé
jusqu'ici Gérald Darmanin seul au
manette Gérald Darmanin avec qui
effectivement les relations sont
notoirement fraîches ambiance pôle Nord
avec l'élu de tourcoin au printemps à
l'été dernier il faut dire que Géral
Darmanin avait donciché affiché ses
ambitions pour Matignon qu'avec le
projet de loi immigration il voulait
vous l'avez dit jean-aric faire la
démonstration de sa méthode de son sens
politique de sa capacité à réformer en
mode rampe de lancement pour Matignon
voire pour 2027 est-ce qu'il a perdu la
main le ministre de l'Intérieur s
quelque peu carbonisé effectivement
géréral dararmanin dans sa tambouille
auprès des parlementaires car non on ne
peut pas être d'accord avec tout le
monde et surtout pas avec Bruno retaot
et sachaoulier la droite sénatoriale et
l'aile gauche de renaissance sur le
sujet de l' tion le en même temps a donc
encore prouvé une nouvelle fois ses
limites et puis il y a eu des
maladresses à un moment crucial le
weekend dernier lorsque gerérald
Darmanin s'est affiché avec Christian
estroszi ennemi juré d'éic cotti à Nice
et dans le restaurant préféré d'Eric
cotti juste en face de sa permanence on
va dire que ça n'a pas aidé désormais
donc Gérald haranin et personna non
grata auprès de LR oui ericti avait
parlé de de de mépris pour caractériser
l'attitude du ministre de l'Intérieur
sauf que cette équation c'est la même
pour éisabeth borne elle doit mettre
d'accord Sacha Houlier et Bruno
rotaillot tout à fait le problème il
reste entier aujourd'hui la stratégie
c'est toujours de trouver un accord
entre Renaissance ELR c'est ce qu'on a
pu constater cette semaine alors des
questions au gouvernement à l'Assemblée
comme au Sénat où Elisabeth borne n'a
cessé de dénoncer l'alliance de l'anupe
et de l'extrême droite dans l'adoption
de la motion de rejet lundi mais elle a
épargné soigneusement les élus LR qui
ont joint leur voix pour rejeter le
texte du Gouvernement c'est ce qu'on
prend aussi c'est ce qu'on comprend
aussi avec les personnalités qu'elle
reçoit depuis hier or il faut faudrait
quand même être dev pour savoir si LR et
Renaissance peuvent encore se mettre
d'accord et pour comprendre ce que les
uns et les autres sont réellement prêts
à lâcher éisabet borne peut-elle y
arriver ah oui hein il est empoisonné le
cadeau laissé par Gérald daran les LR
ont déjà fait la preuve qu'ils étaient
des alliés très fragile qu'è la réforme
des retraites et cette fois-ci si on
lâche tout à LR et bien on sacrifie
autant dans l'aile gauche de la majorité
la méthode borne de la concertation et
bien elle avait déjà montré ses limites
lors de la réforme des retraites on
avait pas pu la faire passer autrement
par un 493 ce qui semble cette fois-ci
exclu d'autant qu'on n'est pas sûr qu'on
en a encore réellement un en réserve et
puis il y a un an je voudrais quand me
dire un mot sur ce que disait ellisabeth
born elle avait confié c'est peut-être
ce que distingue des garçons al les
garçons c'était Gérald Darmanin Bruno Le
Maire hein tous ces gens de du
gouvernement ils sont dans les médias à
hurler leur position moi je cherche des
chemins et à la fin j'arrive souvent là
où je veux donc c'est pas la même
méthode effectivement que la méthode
bornne c'est pas la méthode d'armanin
mais lundi si ça ne passe pas en CMP et
que ça casse ça les cassera tous les
deux alors est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça tiens Jean gar est-ce que Gérald
d'Anin peut entraîner isisabeth borne
dans sa chure ça les cassera tous les
deuxam moi d'abord je je pense qu'il est
possible que une solution soit soit
trouvée on voit bien qu qu'en ce moment
déjà des des concessions sont sont
faites et je voudrais juste ajouter un
petite chose je je je dévie un tout
petit peu de votre question mais je vais
revenir sur le en même temps le paradoxe
malgré tout c'est que cette loi qui est
une loi effectivement d'en même temps
enfin le projet de géralde armanin est
approuvé par les Français c'est-à-dire
que les français pour une fois en tout
cas le approuve le en même temps car ils
approuvent les mesures de durcissement
des des règles de l'immigration mais ils
approuvent aussi le fameux article 3 qui
est devenu 4 bis et cetera qui
concernait la régularisation des des
trailleurs sans papier est-ce ça montre
pas la coupure entre les Français et le
politique et le Parlement parce que ce
qui peut plaire au français ça plaî pas
du tout au politique et ça peut pas
remporter les suffrages ou très
difficilement en tout cas de de toute
manière ce qui s'est passé avec cette
cette motion de rejet marque une une
coupure parce que ce c'est c'est un
débat qui était attendu en tout cas qui
était je dis pas que les Français
étaient suspendus à ce débat mais ils
attendait qu'il ait un débat
parlementaire sur un enjeu important et
je le répète sur un projet qu'il
soutenait qui était pas du tout par
exemple le cas de la de la réforme des
retraites or ils n'ont pas eu droit à ce
à ce à ce débat et à mon sens c'est
toute la classe politique toute la
classe parlementaire qui en est
responsable et qui va être jugé
responsable par le par les fr alors on
viendra sur Non Non mais pas de souci
comment Géral peut éventuellement
entraîner isizabeth B dans sa chite mais
je vous voyez réagir sur sur les limites
du en même temps et le décalage entre
l'opinion et les politiques sur ce texte
immigration pas forcément d'accord je
crois qu'il faut toujours se méfier sur
des projets de loi qui sont quand même
très techniques les question de
l'article Dr ou de l'article 4 B
vraiment des chusé qui sont très
techniques on peut comprendre quand même
régularisation des des des
travailleurs faut il faut je pense
regarder avec prudence quand même les
sondages sur les projets de loi comme ça
il s'agit pas de dire si on est pour ou
contre la peine de mort enfin c'est
c'est un peu moins binaire que ça et
puis par ailleurs bah ça dépend ce qu'on
veut est-ce qu'on fait le choix de la
démocratie représentative et donc on
passe par une ou deux chambres en
curence nous deux où est-ce qu'on fait
le choix d'une démocratie directe avec
des référendums plus fréquents aux
dernières nouvelles en France on fait
plutôt le choix de la démocratie
représentative on a dit sur tous les
tons depuis juin 2022 que l'Assemblée
nationale était la plus représentative
du pays depuis des décennies bon ben on
l'a effectivement il n'y a pas de
majorité sur ce texte là et au fond ça
fait très longtemps qu'on sait parce que
le débat certes on l'a pas là pendant
les 15 jours qui viennent mais ça fait
un an qu'on l'a et en vérité
l'immigration c'est un sujet qui est
toujours là dans le débat public et et
d'ailleurs il y a ce sentiment de
revivre des des jours qu'on a déjà vécu
notamment sur la FI ité potentielle ou
pas des des députés LR écoutez sur ce
thème Sacha oulier le président
renaissance de la commission des lois à
l'Assemblée la difficulté des
républicains c'est que vous parliez tout
à l'heure de division je crois que leur
groupe est profondément divisé parce que
ce que vous disent les cadres des
républicains n'est pas toujours la
réalité du groupe les républicains et
que pour pour 62 députés républicains
combien de divisions combien de lignes
politiqu et et c'est un petit peu la
difficulté que nous avons aujourd'hui à
tranché c'est est-ce que si un texte CMP
est trouvé si un accord si une
discussion a lieu si nous retirons
certaines choses du texte du Sénat si
nousous en ajoutons d'autres est-ce que
les chefs de cette ce parti sont en
mesure de nous assurer un nombre de voix
suffisants pour que le texte soit adopté
si on se met 30 secondes à la place
d'Élisabeth barne elle doit avoir le le
sentiment de revenir euh ça doit faire 9
mois en arrière quand début de mars elle
disputait avec les députés LR sur la
réforme des retraites jean-gar pourquoi
les et et donc ça revient à la question
de du risque de chute pourquoi les les
mêmes causes ne produiraient pas les
mêmes effets ouii bien bien sûr et on
voit mais toute la question mais on le
voit depuis je dire depuis 2022 toute la
question c'est cette marge de manœuvre
inéante à la majorité relative de d'une
quarantaine de députés qui qu'on qu'on
essaie de rallier du côté de de des des
républicains alors rappelons quand même
que depuis 2022 il y a 60 % à peu près
je crois des des propos des projets des
propositions de Boi qui ont quand même
été voté qui ont trouvé des majorités
oui ça c'est la méthode Elisabeth band
dont on parlait tout à l'heure voilà et
et d'ailleurs à la faveur de ça au
passage isisabeth bne se montre moins
comment dire ectoplasmise que que
certains ne peuvent le dire elle est
quand même là elle continue Géral
armanin c'est un peu brûlé dans cette
affaire mais mais pour revenir au au au
au Républicain tout est là je veux dire
que le le et et je dirais même le on on
a beaucoup de débat en ce moment sur
l'avenir de de de de la fin du du
quinquena sur sur le blocage ou moi je
suis pas dans je suis pas dans dans une
vision catastrophiste mais il est
évident que l'avenir de ce quinquena
passe par les républicains et leur
capacité ou non à trouver un terrain
d'entente mais est-ce qu'ils sont plus
homogènes sur ce thème de je parle des
députés hein LR plus homogènes sur ce
thème de l'immigration qu'il ne l'était
sur le thème des retraites alors pas sûr
en revanche ce qui est certain c'est que
la frontière passe pas exactement h mêit
c'estàdire que sur les retraites vous
aviez vraiment quand même une minorité
du groupe qui était opposé au texte
autour de d'Aurélien Pradier sur
l'immigration moi j'ai été assez
surprise lundi de voir une assez nette
majorité du groupe LR voter pour la
motion de rejet seulement deux votes
contre si ma mémoire est bonne et une
quinzaine d'abstention donc la frontière
passe pas au même endroit mais
effectivement moi je je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que dit sachaoulier
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait vous avez un
groupe LR qui est aujourd'hui un groupe
divers droites de collectivité local en
fait chacun il y a 62 lignes chez LR ben
mais il y a quand même une grosse
différence c'est que lundi ils ont voté
sur le texte amendé par la commission à
l'Assemblée nationale donc il avait été
entièrement retouché par Renaissance
donc l'opposition
est par rapport à toutes les
modifications qui ont été faites et on
connaît pas leur avis sur le texte du
Sénat même ils disent on veut le texte
du Sénat bon alors on sait pas jusqu'à
quel point il voterait pour mais pour
l'instant ils disent on on est homogène
avec les LR du Sénat alors que sur les
retraites ils ont pas du tout été
homogènes pour le coup c'est pas si sûr
qu'ils soit si homogène que qu'ils ont
eu plusieurs position aussi depuis que
le texte est sorti minovembre avec le
notamment réen Pradier qui avait dit bah
je le voterai
pas oui bon voilà alors c'est c'est
c'est députés auto-entrepreneurs je
reprends l'expression Gérald a-t-il
tenté de les de les convaincre de voter
pour sur la immigration en leur
promettant tiens par exemple une
nouvelle gendarmerie c'est ce
qu'affirment les écologistes écoutez
là-dessus la secrétaire nationale de
écologie les veres marine Tondelier ça
doit pas se passer comme ça dans une
démocratie et en fait moi je trouve
extrêmement choquant ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que quand vous êtes un
citoyen pour avoir le droit à la
gendarmerie que vous demandez parce que
vous avez besoin d'assurer la sécurité
votre territoire votre parlementaire
doit se renier en votons un truc à
l'assemblée qui en plus est AB sur le
plan moral qu'il avait pas envie de
voter mais s'il veut sa gendarmerie il
doit faire ça c'est comme ça que ça
marche la démocratie en France
aujourd'hui franchement la manière dont
Monsieur Darmanin occupe ses fonctions
de ministre de l'Intérieur est
extrêmement préoccupante les vers qui
réclam l'ouverture d'une commission
d'enquête à l'Assemblée sur cette
question Mathilde patin est-ce que c'est
est-ce qu'ils ont une chance de
l'obtenir qui décide comment ça marche
ça alors les les les commissions les
commissions d'enquête en fait elles sont
décidées au sein au sein des assemblées
il faut il faut une certaine une
certaine majorité mais il peut avoir une
alliance en fait pour pour réussir à
obtenir une commission d'enquête donc
seul à priori peut-être pas mais s'ils
sont soutenus ça pourrait fonctionner
est-ce que le gouvernement n'est pas
dans le dé tient écouter le le sur sur
l'ampleur de la crise on va on va
évoquer ça maintenant je vous propose ce
chapitre et on écoute le ministre de
l'économie il était sur BFMTV ce matin
il répond à la question de d'apoline de
de Malerbe est-ce une crise politique
majeure absolument pas je pense que
c'est non c'est un échec parlementaire
c'est un échec collectif et je pense
qu'il faut que nous en prenions tous
notre part mais c'est un échec
parlementaire c'est pas une crise
politique gardons notre sang froid oui
il y a eu il y a quelques jours
maintenant un échec politique collectif
à l'assemblée nationale ça ne fait pas
une crise politique alors est-ce que les
uns et les autres vous parlez de crise
politique non non pour moi il y a pas de
crise politique lundi l'Assemblée
nationale a rejeté en première lecture
seulement c'est même pas une lecture
définie en première lecture un texte du
Gouvernement honnêtement dans une
assemblée où il n'y a pas de majorité
quoi de plus poss possible enfin je veux
dire c'est pas ça n'a rien de ça n'a
rien on a quand même été surpris c'était
possible on a quand même été surpris je
suis d'accord par contre c'est un peu
l'alliance en son des portes ouverts de
la carpe et du lapin bref par contre euh
je pense que le gouvernement euh crée
les conditions d'une crise dans le sens
où il a dramatisé les enjeux sur cette
sur ce projet de loi notamment dans les
dernières heures dans le dernier weekend
avant ce fameux vote comme il l'avait
fait juste avant le vote sur les
retraites sur le texte de la CMP sur les
retraites et en fait en créant de la
dramaturgie ben en fait il se met dans
une situation sitation potentiellement
dramatique pour moi le c'est le
gouvernement qui crée les conditions
d'une d'une petite crise politique mais
au fond le pays il est pas bloqué c'est
pas V on est pas votre avis làdus voilà
c'est ce sur quoi je voulais venir
qu'est-ce qu'on entend par crise
politique c'est quand il y a un
véritable blocage des institutions pour
le moment les institutions suivent leur
cours on l'évoqué tout à l'heure en
suivant bah les différents procédés
constitutionnels qui sont possibles en
l'occurrence dans la situation politique
dans laquelle on est à l'Assemblée à
l'Assemblée nationale il est évident que
ça va se se multiplier C situation et on
se retrouve presque dans une situation
un peu à l'américaine où on va justement
essayer d'obtenir des voies à droite à
gauche au centre pour se réunir autour
d'un texte ce qui n'était pas le cas
avant et ce qui nous met dans des
situations où forcément c'est c'est
moins linéaire que ce qu'on a connu
jusqu'à présent mais vous avez pas quand
même je vous posais la question à tous
les trois ce sentiment d'impass quand
même dans dans laquelle est le le
gouvernement quoi comment réformer avec
avec une situation comme celle peut-être
Jean Garry et ensuite je reviens vers
vous c'est alors d'abord je vis dire que
sur la dramatisation moi je je là encore
je pense que la responsabilité n'incombe
pas seulement au gouvernement je
rappelle quand même que la dramatisation
sur cet enjeu elle vient beaucoup des
républicains je pense à Eric cioti et
aux autres elle elle a quand même été
très très très manipulée utilisée
instrumentalisé ce qui se justifie
d'ailleurs puisque'au fond au final de
cette de ce processus ça pourrait être
le texte des justement des des
républicains qui pourraient l'emporter
et de ce fait leur permettre de revenir
un petit peu au centre du jeu ce ce qui
est pour eux quand même ce qui serait un
peu un peu miraculeux mais le à propos
de la crise politique non évidemment là
ça n'est pas une crise politique c'est
une péripétie d'une forme d'impasse
institutionnel ou d'impasse politique
c'est-à-dire que qui est pas nouvelle la
majorité relative on la connaît depuis 2
ans mais enfin
presque mais là c'est un cran
supplémentaire un cran supplémentaire
mais fondamentalement si vous voulez
cette cette structure tripartite de la
de la de l'Assemblée nationale depuis
2022 telle qu'elle fonctionne avec deux
extrêmes qui
sont relativement incapables de
collaborer d'abord ensemble et avec le
le bloc central cette structure là est
totalement incompatible avec les le
fonctionnement institutionnel régulier
de la 5e République la 5e République
s'est fait pour avoir une majorité
absolue solide et une opposition aussi
cohérente et et solide là vous êtes dans
une dans une situation qui évidemment on
pourrait parler presque de crise
permanente mais sauf que comme comme
vous l'avez dit ça continue à
fonctionner et une crise c'est quand
même aussi quand vous avez une émotion
collective du peuple français par
rapport à au déroulé de de sa vie
politique oui effectivement pe on peut
dire que cette Constitution qui a été
conçu en 58 ben finalement elle elle est
elle est bien conçue puisquelle
fonctionne même dans un cas de figure
qui était pas celui pour lequel elle
était prévu oui elle a elle a pas été du
tout prévue pour fonctionner comme ça et
quand le quand on a vu les différentes
réformes avec élection du du président
suffrage universel direct le scrutin
majoritaire unomal à de Tours c'était
vraiment fait pour des des blocs solides
comme comme vous l'avez avancé mais avec
des mécanismes prévus pour encadrer le
Parlement en cas de difficulté et ces
mécanismes continuent à fonctionner
simplement ils ont été un petit peu plus
encadré donc le gouvernement était un
peu plus en recul depuis 2008 on
l'abordera certainement tout à l'heure
pour que justement le Parlement ait un
petit peu plus de marge de manœuvre et
dans une situation politique dans
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui et bien
ça pose un certain nombre de difficultés
mais Rachel garccel on est quand même
dans une situation de difficulté à venir
c déjà vra avant pour l'exécutif à
réformer le pays c'est quand même ça
l'objectif d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
donner le sentiment qu'il peut encore
réformer réformer la France sinon à quoi
vont servir les 3 années avant la fin de
son mandat quoi il y a un double dénis
les opposition à l'Assemblée font comme
si le gouvernement pouvait tomber tous
les 4 matins ce n'est pas vrai le
gouvernement fait comme s'il avait
toujours une majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale on a beaucoup dit
a raison que le gouvernement avait fait
passer une cinquantaine de textes depuis
le début de la législature c'est vrai
mais ce sont des textes souvent mineurs
des projets de loi d'orientation qui
certes où on parle de beaucoup de
milliards mais qui sont jamais forcément
très engageant ou qui n'ont pas nous
interrompre ou qui n'ont pas pris la
lumière médiatique et et donc pas
aglomér les qui la faute en parti au
gouvernement qui a décidé de mettre la
lumière sur les retraites à partir de la
rentrée 2022 et sur l'immigration une
fois les retraitees évacué il a décidé
d'investir sur les d'investir
politiquement sur les deux projets les
plus abrasifs et sur lesquel on savait
que la majorité était la plus aléatoire
en dramatisant l'enjeu il il dit presque
aux oppositions mais faites-nous tomber
là-dessus en fait il y a aucune raison
pas fa on le aurait reproché de ne faire
passer justement que des textes entre
guillemets un peu peuin sauf que je
trouve que le gouvernement depuis 2022
refuse de faire des compromis qu'est-ce
qu'il a vraiment lâché depuis 2022
honnêtement pas grandchose moi je veux
dire que quand même bon on va voir
comment ça va se terminer la semaine
prochaine je pense que si trait du texte
ça peut quand même ouvrir un vrai moment
de de blocage et de crise politique
potentielle pour l'année prochaine et
vous parliez de de de textes qui
effectivement n'étaient pas très
politiqu à part les retraites à part
donc l'immigration cette fois-ci il y a
des réformes très importantes qu'on
attend quand même dans les prochains
mois il y a une réforme
constitutionnelle il y a l'IVG il y a la
fin de vie tout ça ce sont des textes
qui peuvent beaucoup attraper la lumière
sur lesquel il peut y avoir des lourds
désaccords là euh si le gouvernement se
retrouve bloqué de la même façon sur des
textes avec ces symboliques là je pense
que vraiment on sera dans un moment de
de crise importante mathildeman ptin et
on le voit aussi on l'a pas évoqué
récemment
mais je pense aussi qu'il y a un lien
avec le fait que le président Macron ne
peut pas se représenter aux prochaines
élections et ça c'est Nicolas Sarkozi
qui l' avait voulu en 2008 en disant il
faut pas que le président au cours de
son second enfin son deuxème mandat soit
préoccupé par sa réélection pour pouvoir
élaborer des réformes et mener des
réformes et là finalement on assiste un
petit peu à ça avec un président Macron
qui se dit moi je n'ai pas d'enjeu
électoral en 2027 donc j'y vais et puis
on verra bien ce qui se passera oui ça
ça l'hypothèse de Nicolas Sarkozi ça
fonctionnait avec une majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée alors oui mais il va ça
s'est effondré d dès le soir du second
tour des sffondré puis ça s'ffondré pour
lui parce qu'il n'a pas il n'a pas été
réélu mais mais en tout cas on on voit
qu'il y a une volonté présidentielle
différente regardez ce ce sondage
sondage odoxa backbone consulting pour
nos confrères du Figaro réaction de de
l'opinion après cette séquence politique
63 % des français demandent un
changement de Premier ministre et 56 %
la dissolution Jean garig sur le le le
changement de Premier ministre ça aurait
du sens si Emmanuel Macron réussissait à
passer un accord avec les les LR que on
en est plutôt éloigné aujourd'hui on en
est plutôt
éloigné moi il me semble que le perdant
dans dans l'affaire c'est d'abord Gérald
daranin beaucoup plus que qu'Élisabeth
borne et si jamais elle arrivait alors
ça je suis pas prophète h mais jamais
elle bien accord avec la cm puis que le
texte arrivit à passer ce serait au
contraire plutôt une satisfaction je dis
pas une victoire mais une demi-vctoire
pour elle et donc on ne voit pas
aujourd'hui la nécessité d'un Reman il
faut il faut se méfier de de ces
sondages à chaud comme ça qui traduisent
un peu une éptivité et surtout qui
traduisent et ça c'est plus grave c'est
cette cette absence faussé de de de
défiance qui aujourd'hui s par les les
citoyens de leur pouvoir et notamment de
du pouvoir exécutif il y a de toute
manière une défiance donc on voudra
toujours changer de Premier ministre en
revanche il est certain qu'à un moment
donné si on veut continuer et
précisément essayer d'avancer et de
réformer il va falloir un nouveau
souffle et surtout un nouveau type de je
dirais de coalition présidentielle c'est
c'est quand même moi je ne vois pas
d'autres solutions pour la fin du
quinquena qu'une prise en compte de la
droitisation d'abord de l'électorat de
de de de de renaissance et et de et de
la ligne qui qui est
aujourd'hui nécessité je dirais par par
les par les institutions votre avis
Rachel GUC encore je me répète encore
faut-il que les LR le souhaite et voilà
oui après je pense qu'il faut aussi
regarder ce qui se passe dans l'aile
gauche de la majorité bien sûr on risque
de perdre l' gauche de la majorité je
pense que on peut rentrer en crise
politique si par exemple la CMP est
conclusive mais que le texte ne passe
pas par est que la majorité est cassée
sur ce projet de loi là ça pourrait être
vraiment grave alors regardons la la la
composition de cette commission mixte
paritaire puisque on on la connaît
maintenant se députés trois députés
Renaissance à chaoulier Florent bouier
Marie gevennou la modem Elodie Jacquier
Laforge Annie Genevard pour LR les
républicains un député rassemblement
national une députée LFI côté Sénat
cette fois-ci SEP sénateur bah vous les
voyez en même temps
TR LR dont Bruno retaillot un Union
centriste Philippe boncarer deux partis
socialistes et un Renaissance mathilman
patin la présence de Bruno
retaillot président du groupe l au Sénat
au sein de la CMP c'est plutôt
inhabituel qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire
de ça la la composition de la CMP se
fait vraiment en accord au sein au sein
de de chaque assemblée donc en soit il y
a pas de difficulté particulière c'est
vrai qu'en général on prend plutôt les
rapporteurs mais ça il arrive que
justement il des change en disant ben
voilà c'est plutôt toi qui va aller sur
ce texte toi qui va aller sur ce texte
donc je pense que l'idée c'est de
rechercher le le les personnes qui
seront les plus à même de défendre les
les opinions il y a un message très
clair qui est envoyé on va vraiment
défendre la version la version
sénatoriale de de la réforme je on a
fait nos comptes quatre renaissances 4
LR de centristes de socialistes un RN un
LFI c'est quand même un peu difficile de
voir émerger une majorité là-dedans Jean
gar bah si on arrive à trouver un accord
avec les LR c'est c'est toujours pareil
ce qui veut dire présence de retaillot
ce qui veut dire un durcissement du
texte dans le sens voulu par leslr et
pomme de discorde quand même majeur
autour de ce cette régularisation des
des travailleurs sans papier je pense
que c'est là que ça se ça se situe et il
me semble qu'il y a beaucoup en ce
moment de discussion assez assez précise
assez juridique autour de cetteou
également sur la ML méical d'État et les
conditions d'accès aux aides social
c'est d'ailleurs ce que Bruno Leem
disait
je crois que c'est dans une interview
Figaro he c'est ça si je me trompe il
dit si il faut reprendre la version du
Sénat et on a retenu que ça sauf qu'il
rajoute à condition que les LR bouge sur
la me et les conditions d'accès à l'aide
sociale ce qui n'est pas le le le plus
simple Rachel garalccel vous dites que
c'est une boîte noire une CMP pour
pourquoi c'est une boîte noire dans le
sens où c'est des au Sénat je sais que
toutes les commissions sont pas
forcément publ mais c'est vrai donc il y
a pas de caméras il a pas diffusion il y
a certains contre-rendu très précis à
postériori mais surtout les règles de ce
que j'ai compris mais je parle à côté de
spécialiste donc je don parole les
règles en fait sont pas vraiment écrites
c'est sont très flous normalement c'est
censé être les mêmes règles pour que
pour une commission parlementaire normal
mais sauf que de toute évidence c'est
pas ce qui se passe on peut il y a pas
d'amendement il y a pas de délis dépôt
d'amendement par forciorie on peut faire
dans l'ordre mais aussi revenir sur des
choses qu'on a déjà décidé euh au fond
c'est en fait l'une des personnes à qui
j'ai parlé
au fond c'est un moment où les
parlementaires ont presque des des
pouvoirs beaucoup plus forts qu'ils ne
l'ont d'habitude dans la procédure
habituelle votre avis math et patin
justement sur parce que cette fois-ci
elle est je sais pas s'il y a eu
récemment une commission mixte paritaire
à ce point médiatisé à ce point dans la
lumière donc ça donc ça boîte noire dans
la lumière il y a il y a un yatus là
donc en fait les les commissions
mixpitaires don d'abord sont sont
demandé en général par le gouvernement
mais après échappe au gouvernement faut
bien comprendre que la CMP c'est
vraiment entre l'Assemblée nationale et
le Sénat et un fonctionnaire
parlementaire me disait en fait ceux qui
savent comment ça se passe dans une CMP
c'est ceux qui qui ont été parce que en
effet il n'y a pas de règles alors la
plupart du temps les décisions se
prennent avant tractation avec des
tableaux comparatifs des propositions de
texte et quand on regarde les rapports
et bien finalement les rapports bien ne
font que que dire sans qu'on puisse
tracer d'où viennent telle et telle
proposition parce que tout a été décidé
avant c'est aussi l'intérêt qu'on ne
puisse pas savoir vraiment qui a proposé
tel ou tel article ça arrive quand on
narrive pas à obtenir un encore au
préalable que les rapports soient un peu
plus précis et qu'on voit de réelles
discussions en CMP pour aboutir ou ne
pas aboutir à un texte mais c'est c'est
pas forcément le le plus fréquent alors
l'une des questions de ce de cette
journée de ce jeudi elle nous amène au
Conseil constitutionnel ellisabeth borne
pourra-t-elle encore utiliser l'article
493 dans les mois qui viennent je
propose à Steve Jourdain de nous
rejoindre tout de suite sur ce plateau
bonsoir Steve on était suspendu à la
décision du conseil qui est tombé alors
c'était pil poil à 17h comme comme prévu
euh qu'a répondu d'abord voilà faut
expliquer c'est assez complexe 49 et à
quoi et à quoi le Conseil constitionnel
devait répondre précisément l'article
493 il permet de faire adopter un texte
de loi sans vote du Parlement on est un
peu habitué maintenant à ça c'est une
technique qui est très utilisé voire
banalisé par le gouvernement Band qui
l'a déjà utilisé 21 fois depuis le début
du quinquen la dernière bah c'était pas
plus tard que cet après-midi sur le
budget 2024 c'est une pratique qui est
très encadrée depuis 2008 et la réforme
constitutionnelle de Nicolas Sarkozi la
règle est simple l'usage du 493 est
limité à un seul texte de loi par
session parlementa en dehors et c'est
important en dehors des textes
budgétaires Thain oui et la nouveauté
c'est que l'exécutif a tenté de
contourner cette restriction alors là on
est vraiment dans la subtilité de la
technique parlementaire le 25 septembre
l'exécutif convoque une session dite
extraordinaire retenez bien ce mot parce
que c'est important extraordinaire pour
discuter un texte intitulé projet de loi
de programmation des finances publque
pour la période
2023-2027 ce texte n'est pas considéré
comme un texte budgétaire le
gouvernement est donc théoriquement
limité dans son recours au 493 le 13
novembre la date est importante le 13
novembre faute de majorité suffisante
dans l'hémicycle il a décidé de dégainer
écoutez par la présente lettre sur le
fondement de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution j'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement sur le vote en
lecture définitive du projet de loi de
Programm des finances publiques pour les
années 2023 à
2027 en théorie donc Thomas le
gouvernement a déclenché sur ce texte sa
seule et unique cartouche 493 sur la
session parlementaire donc jusqu'au mois
de juin plus de passages en force au
Parlement plus de 493 oui mais non non
l'exécutif a tenté un tour de passp
genre de tour de pass-p je vous disais
que le gouvernement avait convoqué une
session extraordinaire de l'Assemblée
nationale en septembre en utilisant un
493 le problème c'est donc au mois de
novembre il a à nouveau utilis utiliser
l'article 493 sur ce même texte mais
cette fois dans le cadre d'une session
dite ordinaire c'est technique mais les
oppositions notamment le rassemblement
national qui a saisi le Conseil
constitutionnel considère considérrait
que tout cela n'est pas n'était pas très
conforme à notre Constitution la réponse
des sages est tombée aujourd'hui bah si
si c'est bien constitutionnel le
gouvernement n'a pas violé le texte
suprême il il valide donc les choix de
l'exécutif qui devrait donc je mets ça
au conditionnel
ou conséence souhaite uiser ce 49
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas sur le texte
immigration merci beaucoup Steve
Jourdain évidemment je me tourne vers
vous mathilman P parce que là il faut
décoder quand même donc moi ce que j'ai
compris c'est que le Conseil
constitutionnel validait ce qui s'était
passé mais ne n'est pas forcément un
blancin pour l'utilisation du 493 jusque
à la fin juin c'est ça je vais essayer
d'ê d'être très clair il y avait deux
arguments dans la sisine RN je mets de
côté le premier puisquil nous intéresse
un peu moins le deuxième c'était le le
493 a été utilisé pour un même texte en
session extraordinaire et en session
ordinaire donc ce n'est pas conforme et
il était ajouté une petite incise dans
la saisine en disant et puis si c'était
conforme cela voudrait dire que le le
enfin le le 493 ne peut plus être
utilisé en session ordinaire puisque
c'est bon ça a été fait ça a été déjà
fait d'accord mais de cette dernière
petite question ne dépendait pas l'issue
de la question posée au Conseil
constitutionnel on lui demandait juste
est-ce que là ce qui a été est conforme
je rappelle ce que dit le texte oui il
dit que c'est conforme il dit bah le
premier la Constitution nous dit le
Premier ministre peut recourir à cette
procédure pour un autre projet ou une
autre proposition de loi parfin pour une
proposition de loi par session en
l'occurrence il est tre recouru en
session extraordinaire une fois et en
session ordinaire une autre fois pour le
même texte et il nous dit on peut
utiliser le 493 pour un même texte au
cours de sessions différentes bon mais
alors allez-y concluez il rien il ne dit
pas exactement il ne se prononce pas sur
est-ce que on peut à nouveau utiliser
l'ticle pour ça qu'on a envie d' parler
pour savoir si si ellisabeth B va ou non
pouvoir utiliser le 493 et bien le
conseil ne se prononce pas clairement il
nous dit on peut utiliser le 493 sur un
même texte au cours de deux sessions
différentes mais il ne nous dit pas si
ça
any la possibilité de réutiliser le 493
en disant bah finalement comme il y
avait un seul texte on combine et
c'était une seule fois et on a qu'à dire
que c'était la session extra ordinaire
et donc pour la session ordinaire donc
il faut attendre le prochain 493 pour
avoir la réponse parce que s'il y a un
prochain 493 il y aura une saisine et
nous aurons la réponse avec une prise de
risque Rachel garavalcarcel pour pour
ellisabeth bnun de plus quoi évidemment
une prise de risque après euh comment
dire euh le Conseil constitutionnel il a
quand même pas l'habitude de mettre trop
de bâtons dans les roues de l'exécutif
hein c'est il fait un peu de politique
aussi c'estàd que c'est vous dites ça
peu de politique oui euh oui juge enroit
mais c'est pas tout à fait des juristes
qui sont là enfin pas que enfin euh en
fait on avait beaucoup regardé le
Conseil constitutionnel des des des des
recours sur la réforme des retraites
j'avais des des constitutionnalistes qui
m'avaient dit mais à l'origine certains
constitutionnalistes de de 1958 disaient
au fond le conseil constinel ce sont des
canons braqués sur le Parlement pas sur
l'élycée donc moi j'ai tendance à passer
penser que il facilitera la vie du
gouvernement par contre on ouvre une
boîte de pend c'est cas là j'an gar
votre avis là-dessus parce que c'était
une manœuvre assez habile du
rassemblement national euh dans dans sa
logique de voilà normalisation
normalisation merci je cherchais le mot
euh est-ce que on peut dire que le
Conseil constitutionnel fait un peu de
politique aussi veut pas donner raison
au rassemblement national en tout cas il
y a beaucoup d'interrogations
aujourd'hui sur la nature de la
composition du Conseil constitutionnel
certains juristes notamment mais vous
savez ça mieux que moi considèrent que
il serait souhaitable que la composition
du Conseil constitutionnel soit purement
juridique c'està que ça soit uniquement
des experts juristes et qu'il n'y ait
pas des éléments qui soient nommés par
par le le le les les acteurs publics
c'estàdire le président de la République
Premier ministre donc ce serait
président d'assemblée pardon et donc
effectivement il y a un doute qui qui
qui pèse sur j'allais dire la la
neutralité des décisions du Conseil
constitutionnel et c'est un doute
politique et je pense que si révision il
y a révision institutionnelle ça
pourrait ça devrait à mon sens par
rapport à à tous les problèmes qui qui
ont été soulevés depuis la la crise des
retraites ça devrait être quelque chose
qui pourrait être mis sur la table cette
composition du Conseil constitutionnel
et cette cette manière de faire échapper
le Conseil constitutionnel à une logique
politique alors pour l'instant ça n'est
pas prévu par le gouvernement utiliser
le 493 sur l'immigration sur le texte
immigration mais matine patin a priori
si on a compris la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel ce serait possible ou
pas on sait pas c'est ça le conseil se
garde bien de
répondre toujours oui le faire en
prenant le risque d'être retoqué mais
alors en réalité les deux
interprétations sont possibles quand on
en revient à la lettre du texte à priori
c'est un texte par session même si c'est
le même texte et le vous parliez de
boîte de Pandore il faudrait alors que
le Conseil constitutionnel en cadre s'il
décidait qu'on pe réutiliser l'article
493 parce que c'était le même texte la
première fois h extinaire iludrait
encadrer cet usage pour éviter just vous
l'évoquz bien le fait de d'ouvrir des
sessions extraordinaires pour pouvoir
commencer un 493 et le continuer ensuite
et donc multiplier les 493 contrairement
à l'esprit de la révision 2008 qui avait
restreint cette utilisation merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat j'ai rappelé Jean garig le
titre de votre livre jours heureux quand
les Français rêvaient ensemble livre qui
est publié aux éditions
paillo merci on en est loin oui